buena noche es el momento de actualizar
las principales noticias en materia
económica junto a daniela blandón y
comenzamos hablando bueno de la víspera
no de las tan esperadas e históricas de
elecciones presidenciales de eeuu cómo
se están comportando los mercados en la
víspera de los comicios
santiago muy buenas noches pues bien en
general hoy hubo un buen ánimo de los
mercados a la espera de los resultados
eso pasar de que en días anteriores
habían estado golpeados por los mayores
confinamientos por culpa de la pandemia
wall street tuvo ganancias en todos sus
índices por ejemplo en europa hubo
incluso mejores resultados con casi
todas las bolsas principales subiendo
más del 2 por ciento américa latina pero
muy poco por ser día festivo en varios
países en argentina subió más del 4 por
ciento el dato curioso que le tengo es
que la industria de apuestas estima que
en la víspera de las elecciones se
apostaron unos 1.300 millones de dólares
a nivel global
betfair que es una de las empresas de
apuestas reportó hoy que la mayor
apuesta política de todos los tiempos se
hizo a favor de joe biden por 13
millones
de dólares nos quedamos un poquito más
en eeuu en la recta final hacia la casa
blanca como recibe el país en materia
económica a quién será el próximo
presidente lo primero que hay que hacer
es recordar que los inversionistas
podrían enfrentar caminos drásticamente
diferentes en impuestos en gasto público
en comercio y en regulación dependiendo
de quién se quede con la presidencia
pero es bueno darle un vistazo a lo que
tenemos hoy el próximo inquilino de la
casa blanca recibe una economía que se
recupera lentamente de los efectos de la
pandemia en 2019 el pib había crecido un
23 por ciento como observamos en el
gráfico ya en los dos primeros
trimestres se redujo drásticamente
frente a los anteriores y en el tercer
trimestre mostró una recuperación y va
creciendo al 7 4 % y en término usted de
desempleo es bien conocido que el país
gozaba de la mejor tasa en medio siglo
antes de la pandemia que era el 35 por
ciento después con un pico del 14 7 por
ciento el más alto desde la gran
depresión
ha venido recuperando ya en septiembre
era del 79 % una barrida demócrata
plantea preocupaciones para los
inversionistas en acciones porque podría
venir un aumento en los impuestos
corporativos por el lado republicano
una victoria de trompo plantearía
incertidumbre sobre las negociaciones
sobre todo con china y con otros socios
comerciales continuamos danielle en
américa latina' vamos a perú que están a
punto de permitir nuevos retiros
anticipados de pensiones no un alivio
quizás para los pensionados si el
congreso aprobó una ley que les
permitiría a los ciudadanos retirar un
porcentaje adicional de lo que tienen
ahorrado en los fondos de pensiones esto
como se lo decía para aliviar el golpe
económico de la panda aquellos afiliados
que no hayan cotizado durante los
últimos 12 meses podrán retirar hasta 17
mil 200 soles que son unos 4700 dólares
en abril una ley similar aprobó el
retiro del 25 por ciento de estos
ahorros hasta un máximo de 12 mil 900
soles o sea 3 mil 500 dólares ahora pasa
a sanción presidencial pero santiago el
gobierno de martín vizcarra se opone
dice que
segunda ola de retiros afectaría
gravemente la solvencia del sistema
financiero vamos hablar de algo que
llama poderosamente la atención vamos a
reino unido burger king nos está
pidiéndole a sus clientes que compren en
su competencia en mcdonald's yo soy la
misma cara que ustedes santiago porque
no fue un error del community manager no
la razón que dio marketing a sus
clientes en reino unido fue justamente
en la pandemia el mensaje publicado en
twitter comienza diciendo nunca pensamos
que íbamos a pedirte esto y continúa
invitando a ordenar comida no sólo a su
histórico rival mcdonald's también a kfc
as a buey a domino's pizza entre muchos
otros
esta es una especie de protesta por el
nuevo confinamiento en el reino unido
que incluye el cierre de restaurantes
por eso porque quien pide que ordenen
comida así sea a la competencia o el que
sea pero que ordenen y ayuden a salvar
los miles de empleos la publicación
también dejó espacio para el sarcasmo
pues termina diciendo un mover ese
siempre lo mejor para una big mac no
está tan mal
ahora entendemos mejor porque él
finalizamos como siempre con la esperada
cifra del día 0 centavos así como lo oye
será el valor que van a pagar los
siguientes 15 días los visitantes a
machu picchu la principal atracción
turística del perú esta joya
arquitectónica acaba de reabrir sus
puertas tras ocho meses de parálisis y
no constaban afortunado los que puedan
visitar la unidad muchísimas gracias por
esta completísima crónica económica y a
nuestra audiencia como siempre los
invitamos a continuar informándose en el
resto de nuestra programación y en
france24 punto com
y